irresponsible what did you mean by that
like if it depends which where you are
um and but I think men definitely
because yeah women UM multitask probably
better than men using your brain and
being logical okay yeah so kind of an
example can I have an example no there
can be do you mean so I don't just want
to say that women or women are just
completely logical and that if you do
give this power to men they would be so
much more responsible and more logical
really I think they'd be much more
responsible with it especially with the
way the laws are now I mean like you
don't want to you don't want to knock up
the wrong girl you're gonna be paying
for it for 20 years maybe they would be
more responsible because more times than
men don't want the child so they
probably would be more responsible about
it
um
probably well in regards to taking the
contraception but if they're not
responsible without it yeah then what
would make them more responsible with it
because I feel like men just lean on the
fact that oh I just need I just have one
thing to do and that is only my response
yeah but they're nothing they're not
silly to the consequence of that yeah
exactly no they're not for like now it's
just like the responsibility is off me
yeah it's like I can do whatever I want
and you know if as long as I have
protection then that's my duty that's my
like everything else is not me right now
so if you were to reverse the roles they
would have to think more oh well I need
to do this I need to do this they would
have to be more responsible I wouldn't
say that men would think that it's not
me but say for example you are taken
contraception we ain't taking condoms
and let's say for example we made a
woman pregnant we have no power anyway
so I wouldn't say automatically men are
like okay cool there's nothing more I I
say I'm done it's more like okay this is
all I can do
yeah because for example if we could
equally make a decision whether this
child can be born or not I'm pretty sure
men will give more input but how many
times have you heard men trying to give
an opinion and a woman's like nope what
I say is what it is yeah that's true
some say and also another point I was
gonna add is
it's a lot of the times due to the
emotional attachment of the baby grain
inside you sometimes your decisions may
not be for the best because as men we
don't go through that our brains are
always going to think more logically
because we don't have that attachment so
we might I might be like for example my
lifestyle right now isn't ready for a
child when you're alive how I feel right
now it doesn't make sense to me getting
this baby because I'm gonna I know how
I'm gonna feel after that but I'm
thinking if we bring this into the world
our financial situation or our living
situation is not beneficial for this
child so it's better that we don't have
this child but that's once you've
already conceived how is my life going
to change
do you guys think what she's saying is
true just by and large the guys in the
room no I I think most men do think
about
the call directions
it's
unfortunate that you know sometimes
babies are born
um
but I know speaking for myself I I I
think about all the consequences of all
the actions that I do before I get into
anything you know
um I'm I try and take responsibility for
the actions that I take and I try and
always preempt what might happen if I
engage in a particular act no matter
what it is so
but I don't know I'm just looking from a
perspective of like let's say night club
State I don't think many guys drink and
think like oh I might get pregnant they
just see a hot ass and they go for it
and then also I didn't do that too also
to add to that so if a woman is just as
irresponsible as a man is for example
let's say
I'm gonna have sex with someone for
example if this woman doesn't really
care at all about contraception anything
then it's like okay if you don't care
more times I'm not gonna care but you
should feel very serious about the
protection that's going to make me
serious but you should put your own life
in your hands knowing some strangers to
your man because now you're giving your
life or your you know how your life is
gonna go to some stranger if you're easy
I'm easy if you're serious then I'm more
protected that's you shouldn't do that
well then I think the decisions we make
are based on get pregnant what happens
you're still building I can see you move
to Miami for a new job and you know you
see a child once a week almost a year or
something but you can't so is that okay
I'm just saying that that's the risk for
them is way less yeah I think the risk
is more for men more yeah having a kid
with the wrong girl it can ruin your
life you could be on child support for
18 years people commit suicide over not
still part to blame
um I mean I I don't think it's why I
have a friend that we know personally
and
he was with his um wife at the time but
you today
disagreements for example he is fighting
fighting hard to get some form of
custody over their child
but because she is the female she gets
more priority and he's fighting fighting
fighting to the point where he told me
how stressed he is sleepless nights
wanting to see his children but she's
just like no and then and they're not
really giving him the time of day
do you not think in that situation I've
seen a lot of women know the man very
well they know how to push the buttons
and the man just doesn't know how to
control that woman like sometimes if you
just give a woman silence she'll come to
you and say oh can you see the child or
something like that you know so I feel
like those men did not maybe as equipped
or or mentally they're just going the
wrong route you know where the woman has
all the power and you just keep begging
her or you know but then why does he
have to beg to see his child no if he
stops she will come after USA okay can
you guarantee that there's not every
woman may think like some women you need
to try some women are just spiteful I
think but it's like that shouldn't be
legal yeah yeah it's very wrong because
if the other way around I'm pretty sure
the same energy that's being pulled
towards him wouldn't be full I think it
takes a strong man to control a woman
and not have that baby drama but there's
a way you can do it
what do you what do you guys think yeah
yeah there's a plan you can do it yeah I
mean like do you think it's easy to
control baby mamas
yeah but there's a way but it's
difficult but it's possible it depends
on your situation yeah it is possible
yeah
what do you guys think yeah no the issue
I have here is the whole point of it's
got to be a strong man to control a
woman but in the same way you still be
criticizing a man if you're not feeling
his role as a father so it's like I have
a way as a man is like why does every
man have to be strong to be able to have
it's hard to be a man to their child so
I'm saying it can be a hard life for a
man I feel like right from the start of
the problems if she starts giving
problems referring to the baby mama
don't like seeing baby mama the mother
of your child and stuff yeah you got to
give the impression that you're ready to
walk away and it's a lot of times if you
give that impression that you're ready
to work and mean it yeah trust me things
gonna go your way when she knows your
thing and you're gonna be there and
Chase Chase she's gonna make it harder
that's my what I think I have experience
for my childhood and then if I do walk
away thinking that it might work you can
come back you ain't doing right by your
child it doesn't matter your child will
know when you grow up you can tell well
I know there's damage but you know know
you can walk away for a year I swear
she's gonna come back and say can you
see your child
she might not this is all assumptions
right now you said that you know there
might be damage to the child but what
about you you've missed a year of your
child's life like yeah maybe the child
in the future won't remember they might
but whatever in the first four years the
first four years of life that's when the
most development happens exactly like I
I know um a decent amount about adoption
and like this relates to us but yeah
because my parents adopted three
teenagers but a lot of times like even
if you adopt a four or five-year-old and
they don't remember like before they're
they're so psychologically damaged from
like going from different caretakers
that like I have a friend um that I knew
through church and like she had
um a brother that was just like so
damaged from the first four years of his
life being and so in being with
inconsistent caretakers that had damaged
him for life and he was always like the
problem kid in the family I mean it is
unfair
um the the power between women and men
when there's you know they're not
together and there's a child is just a
lot of disadvantages it's very unfair
um especially even less no matter how
much you end there should be like a cut
off point I feel that as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible